as a result of what has happened in
Ukraine other countries of Eastern
Europe particularly Poland Lithuania
Latvia and Estonia all members of NATO
since 2004 are increasingly concerned
about the credibility of the commitments
that were made to them to protect them
particularly from the Russians Russia is
a great power it regards the
incorporation of these countries into
the EU and in tomato as a threat and it
is determined to gradually roll that
back there is a great danger that if the
West were to try to reassure its eastern
allies by sending more troops there
could be a very violent response from
Russia it's important to understand that
from the Russian perspective they were
promised that NATO would not expand
eastward after the Berlin wall collapsed
take the example of South Korea in South
Korea the United States has 30,000
troops they serve as a tripwire in the
event of a North Korean invasion in
effect the United States is at war you
don't have anything like that kind of a
commitment a physical commitment made in
Eastern Europe so their question then
becomes does NATO have the wherewithal
to defend these countries from a Russian
invasion the answer is right now on the
ground no the alternative would be
perhaps to threaten the use of nuclear
weapons and quite frankly I don't think
that that's necessarily very credible
it's not clear to me that any of the
countries of the Western alliance would
be willing to risk nuclear war in order
to defend the sovereignty of Estonia